bonjour à vous je voulais commencer par
cette phrase de mandela qui disait ne me
jugez pas sur mes succès mais jugez-moi
au nombre de fois que je suis tombé et
je me suis relevé alors je vais essayer
en 18 minutes de vous dire combien de
fois je suis tombé et combien de fois je
me suis relevé je vais vous le décrire
en trois parties qui pour moi sont les
fondations la résilience est le plus
important
la main de dieu
avant ça et c'est moi me présenter je
m'appelle jean luc à bout conan je suis
né le 31 mars 1973
oth chu de treichville j'avais moins de
2 kg donc j'ai appris très tôt à me
relever en 2009 et j'ai eu l'idée de
créer une banque mais une banque
différente pas une banque pour financer
les grandes entreprises pas non plus une
banque pour faire de la microfinance
comme tout le monde je voulais une
banque pour accompagner la coiffeuse la
couturière
le boulanger pour leur donner un type de
financement qui ferait qu' il soit les
grandes entreprises de demain
je m'en suis ouvert à quelques aînés qui
était d'éminents banquiers ils m'ont
tous découragés monde il ne fait pas ça
tu vas perdre de l'argent on peut pas
prêter à cette clientèle
elle est pas fiable et il y en a même un
qui m'a dit mais toi tu es déjà dg de
bank tu cherches quoi au juste
et j'ai pas écouté on n'avait pas
beaucoup d'argent à l'époque j'ai réuni
quelques amis quelques mais qu'ils
partageaient la même vision que moi et
je leur ai dit écoutez si on arrive à
travailler religieusement pendant
quelque temps on pourra accomplir
quelque chose de grand ils étaient là au
début il y avait serge il y avait là isa
il y avait jacques et ensuite et alice
chengdu adeline alioune je mentionne
leur nom pour que quand ils regardent ce
telex ils sachent que si je suis là
aujourd'hui c'est aussi grâce à eux
en 2014 on a eu notre première licence
on a débuté nos activités c'était en
guinée et dès qu'on a commencé il y
avait d'autres challenge déjà on dit
mais c'est qui ces gens là on les
connaît pas
c'est peut-être des escrocs c'est
peut-être même du blanchiment d'argent
on a tout entendu aujourd'hui trois ans
après on est présent dans 6 pays nous
avons 900 employés nous avons cinquante
mille clients nous avons octroyé 20000
crédit pour plus de 50 milliards à des
maisons entrepreneurs et vous savez pas
quoi
deux des aînés qui me disait qu'on était
fou il travailla koffi n'a aujourd'hui
je vous dis tout ça pour vous dire il
faut jamais laisser des gens vous
détourner de vos rêves
parce que qu'ils vous disent que vous ne
pouvez pas y arriver en fait ils se
parlent à eux mêmes pas à vous et ces
gens là il faut absolument les éloigner
de vous alors dans les moments où je
doute un peu savez ce que je fais
j'écoute des paroles qui me parlent
qu'ils sont des paroles aussi de jeunes
partis d'anoumabo qui ont réinventé les
codes
je vais vous montrer ce que je fais
beauty fois ça
c'est un monde
m
pourquoi on a parlé de fou parce que en
réalité c'est le seul ceux qui sont
suffisamment fou pour penser qu'ils
peuvent réinventer le monde ont des
chances d'y arriver
je vous parlais de la première partie
qui sont les fondations
je pense qu isabelle en a parlé tout à
l'heure on ne peut rien réussir de
durable issa qui est architecte va le
confirmer
100 des fondations solides moi j'ai eu
la chance d'avoir des productions solide
mon père m'a toujours donné de bons
conseils
ma mère qui est présente ici vous aurez
l'occasion de découvrir quand je vais
dérouler un peu plus tard j'ai eu
ensuite ma seconde mère qui en fait
était ma nounou perez qui maniait la
chicotte avec beaucoup de brio
ça fait que vous étiez obligés de
marcher droit
et enfin ma troisième maire c'est rené
mon épouse ll est toujours zen
elle est très spirituel moi je suis très
physique et quand ça va pas et dit ne
t'inquiète pas l'univers pour voir je
vais embrayé sur ce que j'appelle la
résilience car sens résilience
on peut pas y arriver j'ai créé quatre
sociétés une promis dans la restauration
rapide qui a fait faillite
une seconde dans les émissions de
friperie qui a fait faillite
une troisième dans le transport
collectif qui a fait faillite et une
quatrième dans le transit qui a fait
faillite également la cinquième société
que j'ai créée qui était dans la
conception de produits chimiques a bien
fonctionné elle marchait relativement
bien j'ai même ouvert une filiale au
ghana
à l'époque ça s'est développé tout à
coup craque on a eu la rébellion en côte
d'ivoire tous nos marchés sont tombés à
l'eau et là je me suis pas découragé
j'ai dit l'échec
ce n'est qu'une occasion de recommencer
quelque chose en mieux et donc contre
l'avis de tous j'ai confié ma société au
directeur commercial j'ai passé les
concours
je suis retourné en france en master en
ingénierie financière a le fc toulouse
et ensuite en la même année en dss en
banque finance à paris 5
et c'est au terme de cette année de
réapprentissage que ma carrière de
banquier a commencé et d'avoir travaillé
à bnp paribas puis j'ai rejoint city
bank en côte d'ivoire et comme il était
écrit dans mon destin que les choses
devaient jamais se passer simplement un
an après être entré cause de la
situation politique qui avait notre
département décide de transférer toutes
les équipes en afrique du sud et de
laisser les supports ici j'étais analyse
de crédit estimaient qu'ils en avaient
besoin
n'avait pas besoin de nous parce qu'ils
en avaient des moins chères à
johannesbourg et comme en temps celui à
qui j'avais confirma société avait
confondu chiffre d'affaires et bénéfices
j'avais plus de sociétés j'étais pour la
première fois de ma vie au chômage sans
visibilité parce que notre situation
économique à l'époque je vous rappelle
on avait eu un coup d'état de 99 le
complot du cheval blanc
le complot de la mercedes noire le cas
le braquage de la bceao la rébellion ça
faisait beaucoup et dans ces moments là
il faut se tourner aussi vers son
créateur et je vais embrayé sur la
dernière partie qui pour moi est la plus
importante c'est ce que j'appelle la
main de dieu après une semaine de
chômage
j'ai reçu un coup de fil de l'ancien
premier ministre m ahoussou jeannot qui
est à l'époque ministre de l'industrie
et du développement du secteur privé
je ne connaissais pas on avait une
connaissance en commun il m'a appelé il
m'a dit écoutez j'ai entendu parler de
vous
j'ai de grandes ambitions pour mon
ministère on a besoin d'un profil comme
vous qui parlent l'anglais qui connaît
la finance parce qu'on va aller à des
conférences à l'étranger
j'ai hésité un peu et j'ai accepté sans
savoir que c'est cette décision qui
allait me permettre de re devenir
banquier les mêmes personnes qui
m'avaient lice ancien an plus tôt on
rejoint la barclays bank en afrique du
sud il avait besoin de monter un
département qui s'appelle non-présence
quentris c'est une expertise
particulière qui demande de connaître le
correspondant banking mais aussi d'avoir
une connaissance de l'administration
publique parce qu'on prêtait aussi aux
états vous voyez sans le savoir
ce choix que j'avais fait me permettait
d'obtenir mon premier poste de directeur
dans une des plus prestigieuses banques
au monde qui était la barque les à
l'époque et c'est ça aussi la main de
dieu
un jour en mai 2008
j'étais à l'aéroport j'ai quitté accra
pour rejoindre abidjan
j'ai reçu le coup de fil est quelqu'un
je connaissais pas qui me parlait avec
un accent anglophone étrange on m'a dit
bonjour mon nom est honni et lou peilou
je suis le pdg du groupe hugh billet
j'ai entendu parler de vous est-ce que
vous pouvez venir me voir à les gosses à
mes frais je dis bon écoutez je prends
l'avion
j'atterris abidjan si un vol je reviens
vous voir j'ai atterri à abidjan
il y avait un vol deux heures plus tard
j'ai sauté dans l'avion qui arrivait à
les gosses il était 10 heures du soir
je suis arrivé chez lui et retrouver
tout son comité de direction à la maison
il a dit ceci je ne connais pas c'est
pas ce monsieur je les appelais ce matin
il était dans l'avion et il se trouve
avec nous aujourd'hui
en ce qui me concerne il n'ya plus
d'interviews données lui son contrat
voilà comment les signé le plus gros
contrat de ma vie en deux heures de
temps et des choses n'ont plus jamais
été comme avant j'ai été directeur
général du gabon
la filiale se portait bien et tout d'un
coup le groupe décide de ne transférer
au sénégal parce que la fille à l'époque
était déficitaire
c'était un marché que je connaissais pas
qui est en plus très compétitif je me
suis dit qu'est ce qu'on va faire je
suis arrivé au tour 2 août 2010 et
parfois le mois où j'arrivais je reçois
un mail de mon patron qui dit mais tu es
la deuxième filiale qui perd le plus
d'argent dans le groupe g dit mais je
viens d'arriver
quand un peuple est là qu est ce que je
me suis dit la main de dieu on a mis en
place un projet qui s'appelait le projet
120 avec les mêmes équipes qui étaient
comment mettre la banque sur la base une
profitabilité durable en 120 jours
en novembre 2010 la banque dégagé son
premier bénéfice comme si ça devait pas
s'arrêter là
trois mois plus tard on a signé la plus
importante transaction jamais signé par
le groupe immobilier hors du nigeria
faisant de la banque
la principale banque partenaire de
l'état pour les importations de pétrole
et ça m'a permis de gagner deux fois de
suite le titre de banque il d'année au
sénégal
pour faire de la maison finances il faut
des compétences en banque conseil pour
les process est également en
microfinance nous avions les deux
premières pendant que j'étais à la télé
en train de signer pour ce fameux deal
un ami de longue date avec qui j'ai fait
mes études à toulouse qui me voient à la
télé après vingt ans il me reconnais
c'est un sénégalais il voit la qualité
plus âgés comment il dit mais c'est mon
petit et il passe me voir au bureau
pendant qu'on discute
je découvre qu'il était directeur au
crédit mutuel du sénégal qui est la plus
grande institution de microfinance de la
sous-région et sans le savoir le maillon
qui manquait à la chaîne venait d'être
découvert m'a présenté à maré mahb a
obtenu qui était la dg à l'époque et qui
aujourd'hui dgr du groupe qu'au final et
notre institution repose beaucoup
aujourd'hui sur ses épaules c'est devenu
plus qu'une collaboratrice et une soeur
elle est ici dans la salle aujourd'hui
enfin toujours l'âme de dieu on avait
besoin d'avoir notre licence en côte
d'ivoire on n'avait pas assez de
ressources
il y avait un monsieur qui est présent
dans la salle aussi je connais de longue
date c'est un banquier prudent
malheureusement ou heureusement il avait
perdu son boulot il avait eu des
problèmes avec son employeur et je le
connais s'il n'avait pas perdu son
boulot il aurait jamais sauter dans le
bateau koffi n'a heureusement il est
venu et a travaillé gratuitement pour
nous et didier logo qui est présent dans
cette salle jusqu'à ce qu'on obtienne la
licence pour la côte d'ivoire et les
choses se sont mises en place comme ça
les unes après les autres
la dernière chose que je vais vous dire
à ce sujet qui pour moi est la plus
révélatrice de la main de dieu c'est un
jour en 2013 alors qu'on avait déposé
notre licence depuis longtemps et que ça
venait pas vous avez les autorités
décident en parler de ce qui n'est pas
votre contrôle j'ai parlé avec mon
épouse j'ai dit écoute
qu'on commence à resserrer le budget
familial parce que là on n'a pas de
visibilité
je ne savais pas que notre fille qui
avait 5 ans à l'époque d'isa nous
avaient entendu une semaine après la
maîtresse de ma fille parle à ma femme
pour 10 à écouter je suis un peu inquiet
devises allait perturber
parce qu'elle nous a dit papa a dit
qu'on allait parler en vacances cette
année parce qu'à plus d'argent là j'ai
dit qu'ils allaient mettre ta famille ou
encore et le soir alors que j'étais à la
station service
j'ai reçu un sms que je vais vous
montrer parce que je les immortaliser
dans mon bureau ce sms
je vous lis à ce qui est écrit dessus il
est écrit mon fils il ne faut jamais
avoir peur de tout reprendre à zéro
ni de quitter la classe affaires pour
aller en classe économique
les grandes réalisations commence par
des grands sacrifices
cette photo est photos que vous voyez là
c'est la photo de ma mère elle est ici
dans la salle
ce que vous ne savez pas c'est que si
vous avez une pièce de 25 francs cfa
dans votre poche
c'est elle qui est sûre la pièce de 25
francs cfa ce que vous ne savez pas
également
c'est qu'elle était enceinte et deux qui
deux mois donc indirectement je suis sur
la pièce de 25
ce n'est pas un billet de dix mille
c'est une pièce de 25
la pièce qui est destiné à la plus
grande masse ça veut dire que je devais
faire de la maison finances et être
banquier aujourd'hui
phénomène de la main de dieu
on ne peut pas analyser la main de dieu
en regardant devant on ne peut que
constater son effet en regardant
derrière et quand les situations
arrivent il faut faire plus confiance à
son instinct et faire de son mieux en se
disant que la main de dieu va guider
nous pas pour nous emmener dans la bonne
direction à koffi n'a on a voulu faire
une banque différente
on a voulu créer une finance plus
inclusive pour notre continent et on
s'est dit que les vingt mille maisons
entrepreneurs qu'on a financé au cours
des deux dernières années
employé en moyenne cinq personnes
ces cinq personnes la faisait vivre en
moyenne 10 personnes ça veut dire que
mon testament on a pu au cours de ces
deux dernières années impacter la vie de
1 million de personnes et on se dit que
si on poursuit de la même façon dans dix
ans on n'aura plus changé peut-être la
vie de 10 millions de personnes
tout ça pour vous dire que la main de
dieu quand elles se posent sur vous les
portes sur souvent les unes après les
autres comme par enchantement il faut en
faire un bon usage
et quel que soit votre intelligence
négliger jamais la main de dieu je vous
laisse